Have you ever stopped and wondered why our society
kind of has a default setting for who's considered normal?
It's a huge question, and it gets right to the heart
of how our differences have been shaped by history
and by power.
So today, we're gonna dig into the tools
that built this system, and maybe explore what it would take
to build something totally new.
And we're gonna start with this really powerful idea
from the writer and activist Audrey Lord.
What she's telling us here is that our identities,
well, they aren't simple, they're not singular,
they're complex, they're messy, they're all woven together.
And that's a really crucial starting point
for the journey we're about to take.
Okay, so to really get how we got here,
we have to start with a core concept from Lord herself.
It's an idea that quietly shapes
almost every part of our lives,
whether we even realize it or not.
She called it the mythical norm.
And that word, mythical, is so important.
This default person, you know, white, male, straight,
Christian, well off, doesn't really exist as the majority,
but it holds this incredible amount of power.
It becomes the invisible measuring stick
that everyone else is compared to.
And if you fall outside that super narrow definition,
you're automatically seen as different, as other.
So what happens when we meet people
who don't fit that norm?
Well, Lordy argued that we've basically been programmed
with a really limited set of options.
Instead of having a rich toolbox
for how to connect with each other,
we're left with just a few, well, blunt instruments.
Our default settings are pretty stark when you lay them out.
We either pretend the difference doesn't exist,
or we try to copy the dominant form to fit in.
Or in the worst cases,
we try to get rid of whatever we see as being beneath us.
These are the deep, deep patterns
that Lord is asking us to take a hard look at.
And this, right here, this is the core of her message.
The problem isn't that we're all different from one another.
Of course we are.
The real problem is our failure to see those differences,
to understand them, and ultimately to value them.
It's the refusal to engage that creates all the division.
So how in the world does a mythical norm get built
and then force on a global scale?
I mean, an idea this big
doesn't just pop out of thin air, right?
A quick look into colonial history
shows the very real and often brutal ways
these ideas play out.
We're going to look at this through the lens
of something called political homophobia.
Now, this isn't just about personal prejudice.
This is about the deliberate strategic use of fear and hatred
to achieve political goals.
It's a way to build a national identity,
shut down anyone who disagrees,
and keep power in the hands of a small group,
a chillingly effective tool.
Okay, so in many post-colonial countries,
like Nigeria, for example,
you'll hear a common political argument
that laws criminalizing homosexuality
are just about defending traditional authentic values.
But when historians dig into it,
they find a completely different story.
These laws aren't indigenous at all.
They are a direct hangover from the British Empire.
Let's just trace the journey here.
It starts way back in 16th century England
as a political weapon for a king.
Then centuries later, a version of that law,
a version that was actually rejected
for use in Britain itself,
gets written up for a colony in Australia.
And from there, it's imposed on Nigeria.
This was never a reflection of local values.
It was a pure export of colonial power.
And this brings us right back
to one of Audre Lorde's most famous lines.
The colonial legal system,
with all its imposed rules and values,
became the master's tools.
They were designed for one purpose,
to build and maintain the master's house,
the structure of the empire.
And what was the justification for all this?
Well, this quote from a colonial officer
lays it out pretty clearly.
It's this deeply paternalistic worldview, right?
Seeing the people they colonized, not as equals,
but as children who needed parental control.
This was the elitist mindset
that was used to rationalize
the whole project of colonial domination.
So we've seen how these massive power structures
were built throughout history.
But what does it actually feel like
to live inside them today?
Especially when you exist at the crossroads
of more than one identity.
For that, we can turn to the work
of the brilliant legal scholar, Kimberly Crenshaw.
She gave us the term intersectionality.
And it's basically a lens,
a way of seeing the different forms of discrimination,
like racism and sexism,
don't just exist next to each other.
They overlap, they interact,
they pile on top of each other,
creating totally unique experiences of bias.
This quote from Roberto Valdez
just makes that whole academic idea so personal and real.
It's this feeling of pressure to chop up your own identity,
to decide which part of yourself
you're allowed to bring into a room,
because you know the world isn't set up
to see all of you at once.
And this court case shows the real devastating harm
of ignoring intersectionality.
You have five black women
who argued they were fired because of discrimination.
But the court told them, sorry,
you can't be discriminated against as black women.
They said, you have to pick one.
Was it racism or was it sexism?
The legal system literally couldn't see their whole identity
and because of that, they lost their case.
This is the exact problem
Crenshaw and Lorde were talking about.
Okay, so if the old ways of ignoring, copying
or destroying difference are failing us so badly,
what's the alternative?
Where do we go from here?
Let's circle back one last time to Audrey Lorde
for her vision of the future.
Lorde's answer was so clear, it was almost revolutionary.
She said our very survival depends on our ability
to connect across our differences
and to see each other as equals while doing it.
Not in spite of our differences, but with them.
And she even laid out a kind of path forward.
It starts with us, with doing the hard work
of unlearning the toxic stuff society has taught us.
Then it moves outward to really see the differences
among our equals and then to use those differences
not as a wall between us,
but as a source of creativity and strength
and ultimately to completely redefine what power even is.
And all of this leads to her most famous,
most enduring warning.
You cannot fix a system of oppression
using the exact same logic
that created it in the first place.
Trying to fit into the mythical norm
or using tools that refuse to see your whole self
is never going to set you free.
You can't dismantle the master's house
with the master's tools.
So in the end, Lorde leaves us with a challenge,
not a simple answer.
If the old tools of division and hierarchy
and erasure are never gonna work,
then the real question, the one for all of us is this,
what new tools are we gonna build together?